Speaker 1: Let's talk next about a new poll
from CBS News that really highlights the degree
to which we're in serious trouble in this
country because of the things that people
believe disproportionately right wingers,
disproportionately, Republicans disproportionately.
Trump is now some will write in and say, you
know, David, you are overexaggerating the
degree to which these problems are among the
American right.
And I would say, no, I'm not.
The data actually tells us that that's exactly
the case.
So let's take a look at at the poll, CBS News.
Still more to learn about January 6th.
Most Americans say some of the data here is
concerning and some is not.
We'll look at some of the questions when it
comes to the January 6th attack on the capital.
Seventy two percent of Americans say there
is more to learn, and twenty eight percent
say we know all there is to know.
This is one of those questions where in principle
there's nothing concerning here.
It was a complex event in the sense that it
involved a lot of moving parts.
It was multifaceted in that it was Donald
Trump and Republicans and right wing media
and others fomenting the idea that the election
was stolen.
And I would agree there is still more to learn.
The problem is a lot of the people who say
there's still more to learn, what they mean
by that is even at the top level, that this
was violent.
Right wingers inspired by Republicans with
the lie that the election was stolen, which
it wasn't, that's not even something that
they would accept.
So this is actually quite concerning among
Republicans when they were asked about the
actions of those who forced their way into
the Capitol.
The number of Republicans that strongly disapprove
of the riots has declined by 12 points.
In other words, more people now, at least
to some degree, approve of what took place
on January 6th.
And most of that is in somewhat approve.
There's an increase in people that disapprove,
but only somewhat.
And so the point here is the strong Republican
opposition condemnation of what happened on
January 6th has declined 12 points since January.
What how would you describe what happened
at the Capitol?
Fifty five percent of Trump voters describe
what happened at the Capitol as a defense
of freedom, and fifty one percent of Trump
describe what happened at the Capitol as patriotism.
This is absolutely unconscionable.
Now, if you're looking at the graphic, 20
percent of Trump voters call what happened
on the 6th an insurrection.
I'm actually surprised that even 20 percent
of them are willing to call it that.
This is the type of now, I'm not saying these
people are Nazis.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I am saying, though, is that this level
of cognitive dissonance with what took place
on that day is the type of thing that created
a vacuum in which Hitler was able to seize
power in nineteen thirties Germany.
I'm not saying anyone is Hitler.
I'm not saying anyone is a Nazi.
But this is the type of thing where when you
see people this disconnected, 55 percent of
voters say those riots, that violent insurrection
coup attempt, that was a defense of freedom.
That's really, really dangerous stuff.
And in particular, it was a riot fomented
by the then sitting president.
Sixty six percent of all respondents say that
US democracy today is threatened and thirty
four percent say to secure.
This is a really complicated question.
And unfortunately, it's like I don't even
know that these polls give us what we need
to know, because there are people on the left
who believe democracy is threatened because
Trump and Republicans tried to overturn the
overturn the results of the election.
There are people on the right who think that
democracy is threatened because they believe
that Joe Biden didn't really win and is somehow
now the president.
So even a simple question like democracy is
threatened today.
The answer doesn't really tell us much because
the reasons why people say yes very dramatically.
The bottom line is this was an attempt to
overturn the election results based on the
lie that it was stolen, that riotous insurrection
was fomented by the then sitting president.
It was it was bad enough how the right reacted
at the time.
But six months later, they are sort of you
could call it a revisionist history.
You could call it a group delusion, whatever
you call it.
The percentage of Republicans who don't think
it was that serious has gone up in the five
months since of six months since it took place.
And the percentage of Republicans and Trump
voters who say it was a positive act to defend
freedom has gone up dramatically.
So what is the takeaway?
The takeaway continues to be, number one.
I don't know how we fix this.
I just have I'm out of ideas, guys.
Number two, the extremist faction of the Republican
Party is the dominant wing.
If you are a viable Republican in most ways
like Liz Cheney is.
But you think, guys, this election stuff makes
us look stupid.
You are now apparently in the minority in
the Republican Party, at least as far as they're
willing to admit publicly.
And then final takeaway, Joe Manchin and Kirsten
Sinema, two Democratic senators who insist
that we want to find common ground with Republicans,
we want to work together.
We need to find compromise that is between
what Democrats and Republicans want.
These are the people that you are trying to
do that with the people.
Fifty five percent who say the riots were
a defense of freedom, only 20 percent of whom
are willing to say it was an attempted insurrection.
Joe Manchin and Kirsten Sinema, how exactly
do you find common ground with those people?
It's a genuine question.
We're really, really in trouble.
I want to remind you, The David Pakman Show
is not in trouble.
We are actually on the precipice of our 16th
anniversary at the completion of Monday, August
16th.
It will be our 16th anniversary.
And so on the 16th, 16th for 16, it's very
16 related.
We're going to do a membership special.
If you've been thinking of signing up, we're
primarily funded by our viewers and listeners
like you through the membership program Monday,
August 16th.
We'll be doing a big one day membership special.
I hope that you will get on my newsletter
at David Pakman Dotcom and then Monday the
16th, you'll get a fantastic email telling
you how to take advantage of this criminally
low membership discount.
Remember that The David Pakman Show does depend
on the support of great people like you and
even the people who are the haters, but they
still value the show and sign up at Join Pakman
Dotcom.
Our membership program gives you great access,
wide and long access to all sorts of great
member benefits you can sign up at.
Join Pakman dot com.